welcome back to steampunks GameSpot's pc
focus show we talk about PC things and
general gaming things that mostly do it
on PC with me Edmund Tran and you just
McDonnell now call of duty black ops for
making a lot of waves this week there's
like you've blackout mode which is the
Battle Royale spin-off there's a thing
that you know on PCs only available on
battlenet this time round which has
gotten people up in arms but also it
doesn't have a single-player campaign
this time around yeah is what we're
gonna be talking about today
the lack of single-player campaign in
call duty black ops and whether they
need one or whether that's a big deal
and why it's a big deal yeah now I play
multiplayer games but you typically
don't know I typically don't yes to me
but I it occurs to me like I someone
who's sort of outside of it but plays
plenty of games I have tons of different
modes it seems strange for Activision
and Treyarch to hit this point where
they've decided to cut down on their
offerings yeah I'm for the same full
price game I understand for a lot of
people the single-player was just an
inclusion it was kind of a nice addition
yeah that a lot of people still didn't
get into but I think most people that
I've talked to who are big Cod fans
would at least get through the campaign
now have that experience I think crack
will fight you on there unless modes
thing that they included a whole new
better way ow
sure on top of traditional multiplayer
as well as zombies which is always
popular I do get that you know
single-player has traditionally been a
component of a lot of different types of
games but we have also seen the trend of
game shedding this single player
completely the games like titanfall for
example which didn't have a traditional
multiplayer but they went back to it
with titanfall too and you know that was
a really good campaign and then we're
seeing similar stuff with fallout 76 oh
yeah sure obviously Bethesda is a
company known for you know the whole
advertising campaign was we're
supporting single-player experiences yes
from everything that everyone said you
can get away from other plays but there
is no way to play the game where you are
singularly on your own map and there's
nobody else and yeah and you can play
offline which is a really interesting
move and as they've said kind of a risk
for their player yeah
I'm really interested to see how flawed
and out in the in terms of Call of Duty
I'm in sort of two minds of their lack
of single-player the first mind is that
Call of Duty for me has always had
pretty good single-player campaigns and
they've been short and sweet and even if
they're not like amazing they're still
like nice to play for like two or three
hours obviously the campaign in modern
warfare one was like exceptional and one
on warfare sort of single-player
campaigns are still pretty memorable to
me they had a lot of sort of iconic
moments in terms of black ops people
obviously loved the black ops storyline
and they loved you know Frank woods and
all those kind of guys and to see that
kind of go away is really sad but on the
other side of things I totally
understand why it's only multiplayer for
a lot of people who play Call of Duty
multiplayer is all they play and I can
see Treyarch and Activision saying okay
well obviously we're just gonna put all
our money into this side of things and
people are gonna be happy presumably for
a while most people of Duty multiplayer
was on Steam as its entity and people
were just buying that beer and you know
just playing that bit you know like Call
of Duty for a little for a little while
would let you choose which menu you want
to boot into you can just boot into the
multiplayer menu but I think the lack of
single-player thing is more of a coming
from the console side of things where
traditionally consoles have never been
sort of connected because they've always
kind of being connected but on console
where you can just play offline and sort
of have like a solo experience the lack
of single-player kind of speaks to this
changing dynamic of what games are
supposed to be now and that's kind of
something that the game at play base has
kind of been adjusting to for the last
sort of decade or so as you know things
get more interconnected there on the PC
front like PC gamers are no strangers to
multiplayer only games like all the big
PC games all of the biggest PC games are
multiplayer only you got your donors
you've got a long as you've got your
battle Royales none of these games a
single-player and like to just have a
multiplayer game is not a big deal it's
like I'm gonna play this one it's gonna
be online my computer's online already
I'm gonna play with other people and
that's fine it's just part of what PC
gamers expect from games a lot of yeah I
mean I mean I think there's a huge space
you know the the Elder Scrolls games are
the world for that I'm solo experience
but I think one of the weird things
about Activision's choice is that they
likely may have
speculatively moved those resources from
the single campaign into the battle
royale which is giving that mode it
basically needs to be amazing and from
what everyone said it is quite good but
I think it's put a lot of the heavy
lifting on that new mode because
presumably without that maybe we would
have seen another single can play a
campaign in this game multiplayer games
are much more transient you know it's
like if I want to go back and play a
game of call of duty world at war you
know multiplayer I'm not gonna be able
to and you know in 10-15 years time
are we going to be able to go back to
black ops port and you know experience
it because well the service still be
online you know like we want the player
base still be there you know it is a
huge game it probably might be people
still play Modern Warfare on PC all the
time so that you know something not a
worry there but I don't think it's you
know if it's if this becomes like a
wider trend it's kind of problematic
because you're then splitting gamers
across all these different games and you
need to like put a lot of resources into
maintaining the multiplayer base and
making sure that the game exists as a
service yeah let us know what you guys
think particularly in the case of black
ops for if it was indeed a trade-off
between the single-player campaign and
the new battle royale mode blackout are
you happy with that trade which would
you prefer have you feel like Call of
Duty and notice they're all your
thoughts in that comment section below
thank you for all your comments last
week when we talked about the episodic
formula fair games and whether it's good
or not I people just seem to like
waiting for the whole thing yeah which
is totally understandable generally I
find it quite surprising that not many
people like with me unlike the hitman
thing we just like explore a single
space so that's fine
yeah but anyway here and there they were
we did get one particular comment from
agenda on site saying I hate the
episodic formula but I like the games
generally I wait until the game is
released in its entirety before playing
so yeah that was that's basically that
was pretty much everybody I mean I do
think it's still relevant to like think
about how it helps like things like
budget like coming that way yeah it's
like a huge like kind of crappy trailer
on yeah
for the gamer but for them it's probably
ending up with making you a better game
so whether you think that's valuable or
not it's probably no no to her I the as
the old Shigeru Miyamoto quote goes
is eventually good but a rush game is
forever bad that's a good point
cricket style J on YouTube said the
irony of telltale and life is strange is
that story heavy games are probably the
worst possible genre for an episodic
format the drama and story can't be
sustained about all those long gaps
contrast this with shovelknight where
the episodes came out years apart but
it's fine because continuity is not
central to the games appeal I think he
makes a really good point that's in the
case of hitman as well sir you know yeah
obviously gameplay is nice to revisit
after a short break and if you're not
left on a cliffhanger ending then that's
fine it's kind of just like a mini
sequel yeah she's like a nice thing to
have I guess a little present yeah mini
game I think I like the point that was
made about story I do like the
serialization of story I like the way
that television delivers episode but you
know there's a really good reason why TV
shows come out every week because it's
consistent yeah
it's near enough that it's it's giving
you like that way and you're getting
them in like five size chunks but it's
it's yeah it's there's a consistent
expectation of when you're getting it
and I do think that is where the episode
episodic format can fall down when
either there's weights a month or you
don't or when the next ones coming at
all and you're just losing sitting with
the story which is a bit of a shame that
is everything we think but do let us
know your comments on this week's
episode down in that comment section and
we'll be back soon with another PC
focused episode
[Music]